this year we will have been together for
five years
five year he Bobby has had my firm skin
years
you better [ __ ] I know don't get all
in now because it's all downhill from
here
wheeler wet feet I know I know I'm going
in the gym F I've never been a
relationship this long Oh L so a message
to everyone listening hi I've been
playing battlefront Star Wars Star Wars
he and I need people to play with Hey we
have not talked about the Christakis
brothers oh [ __ ] talk about God lobs we
talked about God let me say something
right now guys let's get into it
so I started googling things on YouTube
I've been googling crazy Christians just
resting good I know I love like that
like I like watching people you know
going to speak in tongues or when you
know kids they get possessed in the
middle of street and they you know
documentary we like Jesus camp Jesus
camp yeah yeah is it with kids and camp
being like you ever see a Hell House yes
I have
what's Hell House is a church in Texas
and every year they do a haunted house
but it's people giving abortions and the
Satan okay but the people actually
auditioned for the parts of like actor
pregnant girl who's about to get an
abortion and this guy that guy yeah it's
a big deal in this town and at the end
of this haunted house you can go into a
room and there's an actual like you know
a pasture there or whatever it's a
pastor not pastor Christians and they
they try to you know you can convert
right then they're really so if I'm just
a layman and I'm not like if I'm
basically an atheist well their goal is
that the haunted house is gonna scare
you enough to go I want to be a Chris
that's a conversion houses its basically
what it is yeah is there like a gay room
then yes yeah there's a game that's like
so they do a whole like play basically
of there's an
guy yeah true
they have bass all the abominations are
played out and by actors who are really
into it and when they get the part I
mean you should see like they got a
Scorsese movie exactly like a method ya
know they're like like the insect is
life altering yeah I'm working with the
narrow that that kind of excitement yeah
which is you know you got nothing you
got nothing
it's called Hell house and hot chicken
but anyway so I've been googling stuff
like that and I ran into a jam guys the
Chris August brothers there's these two
twins called Chris Sacca
you guys have to look them up you also
have to follow them on YouTube let me
spell it for you yes CH R is a G is
Chris August brothers okay put a link
you gotta listen to they do these like a
local like Church TV shows and they sing
and they do sketches no their sketches
I'm gonna make you watch a sketch after
this okay both of you okay number one
they're 15 minutes long okay that's
already two okay number two dears they
did this you got our check it out at
listening if you're listening they do a
ventriloquist sketch it's them it's so
unfunny and annoying that I've seen it
eighty times that you keep watching I
cannot stop watching it he cannot I mean
I love it I study scenes and line reader
line readings in there yeah I know their
songs I love it how many followers they
have so on YouTube they have what good
how did you find a channel that's what
surprised how many the subscribers do we
have 77070 and that's like 80,000 yeah
and that's not that good I know compared
to like people who have like that's
better than them
justice will prevail but these two okay
but there's also an interview they do
about you know how they became
Christians mm-hmm I laughed out [ __ ]
loud
I was basically they're like so the
doctor told my our mom not to have baby
is because she has a disease but she had
him anyway and my brother and I were
born and we are allergic to eight
hundred things No including the Sun
including the Sun which is a real thing
for some guys yeah yeah except they're
the tannest daughters find out but
listen in fact we if if the Sun hit our
skin we would instantly die right in
seven years they lived like in a
darkroom right the hell huh right and
then her mom went to a healer a
Christian healer they did a prayer and
now they're just no there are Sun
tanning on the beach I mean you know
it's doctors gonna do anything but the
healer could yeah so now they are stuck
in the 70s with they had like did it's
there the day basically what they are
are Abba ABBA it's perfect but now and
also they're gay they're obviously gay
they're very flamboyant know they're gay
I think they suck dick they have to suck
dick yeah it but behind Jesus back
doesn't like it but maybe there are the
types of Christians that like accept
homosexuality they're not they're not
there they belong to club 36 they do
these real staunch you know born-again
Christian mmm they're hardcore yeah
hardcore
yeah and they believe in the Lord but
you guys have to check them out and
please let's blow them up yeah we're
gonna blow them up I only think someone
should make a movie or a show based on
these two brothers I really do that's
actually good I can see like HBO it's so
it's so loony it's so low perfect so
cruel weird
but um I love you guys and I think that
we should Gilbert we're ready for the
question
yeah oh the question was already fat
[Music]